113 questions about evolution
with john perry evolutionary question
number 22
did the coelacanth stop evolving
now the title of today's video is a
little bit of me just
kind of trolling other science educators
because
you really shouldn't say did the
coelacanth stop evolving
coelocants aren't just one thing they're
not just one species it's an entire
order
of species only two species of
coelacanth are known today but in the
past there were lots of them and they
were very diverse
and then of course the answer to our
question did coelacanth's
stop evolving the answer to that is no
everything
alive is evolving everything is subject
to descent with modification
acted upon by natural selection however
it is true to say that coelocants are in
what is called phenotypic stasis they
are not changing in body shape
very much over the years and especially
if we compare them to mammals they
haven't changed much at all
since the extinction of the dinosaurs so
today we're going to talk about why
that is today's full question comes in
from atif
and i edited this a little bit just for
length but
he says hi john i hope you're doing well
i am from pakistan and i really
appreciate what you're doing thank you
for it i have many questions but let me
just start off with the following why
didn't see the kants or lobe-finned fish
or any other species of antiquity evolve
for all these millions of years
they have evolved but not as much as you
would expect given the period that they
have been extant for
thank you regards atif well this
question
is really cool if you've noticed in the
introduction to the 113 questions about
evolution
i actually have the coelacanth as one of
these
animals that's significant to
evolutionary theory
the coelacanth is an example of a lobe
finned fish and lobe-finned fish helped
us kind of piece together
how it was that arms and legs evolved
lobe-finned fish have
pectoral fins and pelvic fins that are
very
arm and leg like and we can see when we
look at how lobe fin fish use those fins
we can see that they use them for really
fancy
maneuvering in the water so here's the
celer kant doing his thing
if you watch this too long you'll get
dizzy and puke but
the pectoral fins are homologous to our
arms
and the pelvic fins are homologous to
our legs
those fins are on fleshy stalks and
being on fleshy stalks
they can move with incredible
maneuverability and they can really
outmaneuver other types of species and
from this it's not too hard to see how
you can get something that evolves into
something like an arm or a leg
here is a coelacanth there are the lobes
and these things went all out on the
lobes
during evolution so they've actually got
uh let's see they got two pectoral fins
then two pelvic fins which are the ones
in green there the pink one there
is an anal fin that's also on a lobe the
tail you could argue is also on a lobe
it's got a lobe at the end of the tail
and then there's a lobe on the second
dorsal fin
on the top so the front dorsal fin does
not have a lobe but the second one does
so they've got a lot of lobes these see
the cants and they're very good at
maneuvering now
low fin fish are in contrast to
ray-finned fish
ray-finned fish just have these uh they
have these rays
these little tiny little bones that form
their fins
that stick out of kind of a nub it's
actually it's bone and muscle or
cartilage and muscle
but it's embedded in the flesh you don't
have the lobe there so that's
that's the big difference anatomically
and these two groups of fishes
they diverged from each other before
animals crawled out on land or at least
vertebrates crawled out on land so their
divergence was
very very ancient ray finns have had ray
fins ever since that divergence lobe
fins have made
maintain their lobe fins since that
divergence now
tiktaalik and you know these early
vertebrates that came out on land
maybe there were some before tital cuban
they were
lobe-finned fish so actually you know i
said earlier that there's only
uh eight species of lobe-finned fish
alive today
it's not totally true because all
vertebrates all land vertebrates are
technically
within the lobe-finned fish clade we
are if you want to talk this way we are
really weird lobe-finned fish now about
the speed of evolution
here we have on the right we have a
cretaceous coelacanth
and on the left we have a cretaceous
mammal so both of these animals lived at
the same time as the dinosaurs
and since that time since the extinction
of the dinosaurs
mammals have exploded in diversity we
have you know
thousands of species you've got things
as weird and big as elephants and things
as bizarre as bats bats can fly
so from this these cretaceous mammals we
got
amazing diversity and evolutionary just
innovation
but then in coelacanths the two species
of modern coelacanth look
superficially like their extinct
cretaceous cousins why is that
i would want to point out though that
i've kind of cherry-picked the mammal
world
there are a lot of things that still
look like those ancient mammals a lot of
shrews and so on
but still even though i have
cherry-picked mammals are crazy
right so hey coelacanth you know what's
the deal
come on man coelacanths are so similar
to
their ancient you know fossils that
they're often referred to as
living fossils i cannot remember where i
got this picture of this guy
this man going on a walk with his pet
fish
in the forest when the coelacanth was
discovered that it there was still a
species of coelacanth alive there's
actually two species of see the camp
alive today
it was just awesome everyone's like whoa
it's a living fossil
that term living fossil it really
bothers people
these days in fact there are scientific
papers
saying that we should stop calling them
living fossils because when you tell
the general public that the coelacanth
is a living fossil
what a lot of people think is that
coelacanths have not evolved at all like
the modern coelacanth is exactly like
the extinct
seedlings and really to the untrained
eye they do look the same
this paper right here is one paper that
goes over the changes
in coelacanths and argues that we should
stop calling them living fossils
now darwin is the one who coined this
term living fossils
and i i see the use of it i'm not going
to
say who i side with i haven't really
made a decision as to whether or not we
should stop using this word but
you know this paper says we shouldn't
and
they show in the coelacanths here we've
got the modern coelacanth on the left
and it's closest relative in the fossil
record during the cretaceous
on the right again it does take
you have to kind of be trained to know
how different they are
here i've got the fossil see the cans
next to the modern coelacanth and they
look the same to the untrained eye
but here on the left i've got a dog and
a raccoon
and they also look the same to the
untrained eye
i mean the they're nearly identical so
far as
the average joe can tell in this paper
they point out
that in the past coelacanths were a very
diverse
group and they show this drawing which
shows a bunch of different species this
this chart on the right
it shows you know the overall body shape
of various different species
and then it shows actually their genre
of coelacanth and then it shows you know
the the body size so
some of them are like 0.3 meters some
are what's the biggest one is over two
meters
you know i mean they get pretty big and
pretty small
rebelatrix for example i'm not sure if
i'm pronouncing that right but it
appears to have been highly adapted for
high speed swimming so it's this guy
with the
the the pointy tail that's drawn in this
beautiful painting here on the left
that thing we think was probably hunting
high speed
pursuit kind of like a tuna fish is
today they used to be a very diverse
group
this isn't one of the super high speed
ones but this is this one probably was
more of a high speed predator than the
modern coelacanth which
basically just drifts around and here is
one of the the older
groups that's some people group it in
with ceo some people
group it as the sister clade to see the
cans again according to this paper
they're like
look coelacanths have evolved okay
i get it but why didn't they evolve very
much compared to mammals right mammals
have evolved
tremendously over that same amount of
time why haven't the coelacanths
the answer to this is that under most
conditions natural selection maintains
phenotypic stasis and phenotypic stasis
is kind of a fancy word phenotype just
means like the the shape of an organism
so phenotype is different than
genotype so the genes of an animal you
know the sequence of dna
that an organism has that's its genotype
but the actual shape overall shape and
traits of an organism
that's what we call the phenotype and
it's important to distinguish genotype
from phenotype
because genes can actually evolve a lot
while natural selection is maintaining
a a very stable overall shape
and stable number of traits that the
organism has
you can actually have quite a bit of
dancing that goes on under the hood
but the end result is the same so the
genotype can evolve a lot
while the phenotype stays the same and
this is what we see when we look at the
two different species of coelacanth
alive today
their genes are evolving but their
phenotype
is pretty much staying the same they are
in a state of phenotypic
stasis stasis of course means that it's
staying the same
one of the best ways to see why it is
that this happens
why it is that sometimes a species will
get trapped
with a specific phenotype even for
millions of years
is to look at fitness landscapes which
are models
of how it is that evolution works
fitness landscape models
were first developed by seawall wright
in 1932.
i hope i'm saying his name right his
models were
pretty sophisticated and nowadays
they're much more sophisticated still
i'm going to show you a super simplified
cartoon version
of a fitness landscape this is a falcon
that i drew up here and we're going to
look at the fitness landscape
of this falcon and what has just
happened is
falcons normally eat small birds but
we're going to suppose here
a little mind experiment we're going to
suppose that all of the birds
in north america went extinct except for
falcons
so here on the y-axis the vertical axis
we have fitness
of falcon that's what we're measuring
there one through six
i'm not giving units to those numbers
it's just one through six
and then from left to right we have
falcon body size and that's all that's
one through nine
so this falcon there's no more birds for
it to eat so it has to eat mammals
falcons today they will eat mammals from
time to time but they prefer birds
well these are the mammals that i'm
going to say
are available to this falcon so we've
got mice rats rabbits and
goats this is what the fitness landscape
might look like for these falcons
so the little gold blobs here those
represent
the falcon population so there's you
know each one of those globs might
represent a couple hundred birds
and they they are of a particular size
that is the size that they started out
with and we can see that if they were
size number two they'd be doing really
good because they could they could
perfectly hunt rats
if they were size number five they'd be
doing even better because they could
hunt
rabbits if they happened to be size
eight they'd be doing
really really well because they could
hunt these goats and apparently in this
thought experiment there's a lot of
goats and you know not nearly as many
rats
this population is going to gradually
evolve as the generations go on
and we're going to see that natural
selection
pulls things up the closest possible
slope
from their starting position natural
selection is blind you know it would be
great
for these falcons to evolve
body size number eight but that's not
possible from where we're starting
because
we're we're next to the rats and we're
leaning up
the rat hill and that's the way that
natural selection is going to pull us
natural selection maximizes fitness but
it can only do so
blindly which way are we going to go
we're gonna go up the rabbit or the rat
well we're kind of leaning up the rat
already by default so that's the way
we're gonna go
and now we we cannot get to the rabbit
from here we're just
blindly going up and
we have reached the top we're peeking
over a little bit into the mice
but because natural selection is so
blind
it's actually going to sit there on top
of the rats until
the rat population declines once the rat
population declines
then we can start moving up the mice
hill
get some momentum there and then we're
going to just kind of park out
up there and and we will be stuck there
forever unless
the environment changes or there's some
sort of strange mutation
in the falcons that opens up a whole new
situation for them so supposing that all
else stays the same
small body size is what's going to
evolve
in this scenario that we set up for this
falcon
and by the way i'm just i'm faking this
i'm just i just drew something that
would look cool and we just totally
thought experiment but in real fitness
landscapes
they're these mathematical equations the
equation itself figures out
where the population is going to end up
settling anyway
let's scratch that scenario start a
slightly different scenario let's say
that we have a
much larger population of falcons and
they're leaning on the rabbits and
they're also leaning on the rats
and the population is is physically huge
and
there are some pockets of the population
that
don't communicate with other populations
so there's
there's physical barriers between
different groups if you have physical
barriers
between different groups within the
population you can actually get
the population to split and part of it
will start evolving
towards rabbits in this case the other
towards rats so
that's what's gonna happen here we now
have two populations they are still the
same species at this point
but they are diverging in size and if
they ever do meet up again
and mate their children who end up being
kind of in between small and big
they're gonna be sitting at the bottom
of this landscape they're not gonna
survive very well this is the very
beginnings of a speciation event and now
we're settled up on top
of the rabbits here we got a nice the
perfect size body size
five we're hovering around that for our
large population of falcons but the
rabbits are going to respond to this by
you know the smaller ones dying and the
larger ones surviving and having babies
so actually the rabbit
population is going to change and that's
going to make the falcons
have to change as well this is an
evolutionary arms race
between falcon and rabbit both are
increasing in size
and the goat is starting to get nervous
over here because
what are you doing rabbit you're
bringing me a new
villain thank you so very much this
continues
continues and
goats now hate rabbits because
now the goats babies are getting eaten
and look up
now even some of the goats young older
young are getting eaten by falcons and
oh look
now adult goats are getting eaten
by giant falcons so that's how these
fitness landscapes work
and you probably notice that things tend
to get
perched on the peak of a fitness
landscape
and they just stay there and they really
do stay there i mean obviously
in real life that the landscape itself
is fairly dynamic things are bouncing
around a bit
but natural selection is an optimizer
and the things that keep
the population at the top of the
fitness peak those things are
competition
and mutation rate competition between
other members of their own species and
competition between
other predators you know different
species that's what's keeping them
at the top of this fitness peak any
mutation to the left any mutation to the
right those are damaging to the animals
that possess them and so they don't pass
on very many offspring
mutation rates also affect how tightly
a species gets stuck at the top of a
fitness peak but
i won't go into the details of that
right now there are two main ways to get
off of a fitness landscape and start
evolving again
and diverging and actually splitting
into new species
one of those is an adaptive breakthrough
so let's suppose here that this little
guy
develops an immunity to snake venom well
that will dramatically change the
fitness landscape for this species they
can now eat snakes
there's no longer any really solid
pressure on body size there's lots of
different sized
snakes and so you can see
that under this scenario the the body
size trait might start evolving all over
the place
because these things are now
specializing in eating snakes
of all shapes and sizes so that's one
way to break free
from a peak is a you know crazy adaptive
breakthrough
another way scratch that is for
the environment to dramatically change
and the most dramatic change in an
environment
is a mass extinction and so here we have
everything has now gone extinct except
for one species or one population
of falcons and they're all i don't know
eating bugs and
sometimes even plants rotting carcasses
you name it life just got really really
really rough
during an extinction event and after an
extinction event
the fitness landscape it isn't just flat
and
and it doesn't just stay still it's
bouncing all over the place
it's a lot of luck as to who survives
and who doesn't
whoever does survive they will end up
evolving all over the place
it's pretty much just random true random
evolution happening at this point
but eventually the ecosystems will start
to
come back together and little fitness
peaks will start to stabilize
and when they do this species that
survive the extinction event has now
spread out
phenotypically all over the place and
there's going to be
rapid speciation that is one way to
escape
phenotypic stasis now
back to our coelacanth the coelacanth
appears to be stuck
on a fitness peak and it's been stuck
since the cretaceous
and if we look at this chart we see or
we can kind of get some ideas as to why
that might be
actually is what i should say we know
that the reason
things stop evolving phenotypically is
because they get stuck
on the tops of fitness landscapes but
it's really hard to tell
exactly why they're stuck on the top of
a fitness landscape so now i'm gonna go
into speculation
mode all right so take all of this with
a grain of salt
lobe thin fish if you look at their
history they they emerge in the devonian
and they do okay for a while and then
they really shrink towards the end of
the permian then there's an extinction
event that wipes out a lot of fish
and then lobe-finned fish diversify
after that
a fair amount including coelacanths and
then they
start to narrow as ray-finn fish
start to expand and then these charts by
the way you need to take with a grain of
salt as well
you're basing it off of fossils and the
fossil record is spotty
but it seems like lobe-finned fish took
a hit
during the end of the cretaceous and it
looks like what might have been
happening is they were out competed by
ray finn fishes so after that big
extinction event
when there was this incredible
opportunity to diverge
the ray finn fish diverged first and put
a bunch
of competition pressure on coelacanths
and other lobe-finned fish they weren't
able to diverge
one of the fun things to think about is
you know
why is it that ray finn fish
did so good why do they out compete
everything else
you can actually see at the end of the
triassic if you look at the fossil
record
that they start winning they start
diverging
and taking over and people have
speculated as to why that is like
what was it that ray finn fish hit on
that made them so successful
the most obvious candidate is this
ability right here
they can shoot their mouths forward if
you were to see them hunt
with this structure this puckering face
you wouldn't be able to see it it'd be
like lightning speed they do it super
quick but what happens is
when they open their mouth they suck in
and then they push their face out at the
same time
and they're able to suck up their prey
super super efficiently
and see the camps never evolved this
ability
this evolved twice in two different
species of ray-finned fish
and those species ended up just
exploding and diverging
into thousands of other species and
today pretty much all the modern
ray-finned fish not all of them
but a lot of them are descendants of one
of those two original species
and they have this ability or some
modified version of it
they are by far the most successful
types of fish
on earth today but the coelacanths still
have
one edge over those rayfin fish and that
is that they can maneuver
super super well so if we look at
coelacanths
on a fitness landscape during the
cretaceous
down here on the bottom i have
maneuverability on the left
and speed on the right that's the trait
from left to right
that we're measuring and then i've got
the fitness
i still wrote fitness of falcon on the
side there that should be fitness of
coelacanth
but here we have everyone doing pretty
well they're all on their little fitness
landscapes
and then the rayfin fish come in with
their
super fancy mouths and start competing
and what does that do
well that narrows and lowers the fitness
landscapes of everybody who's alive
the mediocre guy in the middle he's he's
going first
he's on the way out here and he he just
got pushed to extinction
and our really high speed see the kant
he's also not doing so well he can't
compete
quite quite as well with these these
rayfin fish some of them are also really
fast
and they have this crazy mouth and so
look he's going extinct as well
and our highly maneuverable see the camp
still hanging in there but that spike is
now
very very narrow this coelacanth must
maintain high maneuverability any any
mutation to the left
or to the right that lowers that high
maneuverability
that is fatal and so with with all this
competition
all around it cannot change it is stuck
on a fitness peak and it cannot get off
so there we have it still there even
today
again i want to point out that i'm
saying that
maneuverability is the thing keeping the
coelacanth alive
but that is speculation what we can say
with a high degree of confidence is that
the reason the coelacanth has not
evolved
is because for some reason it is stuck
on
a fitness peak so that video was a
little bit longer than i normally like
to make these but i
i love this topic and i really like
looking at and thinking about
fitness landscapes now i will do a video
in the future
just on fitness landscapes because in
reality they're not so cartoony and
silly as
the ones that i showed here atif my
friend from pakistan
i hope that my answer was helpful for
you so long for this week everyone
next question
see the cans more like
sila can't really evolve very much
am i right
okay bye